what is Olivia Rodriguez's most streamed
song driver's license good for you it's
good for you wow that's cool thanks
guys um good for you I think I was
rightfully really nervous that I was
going to be one hit wonder nothing wrong
with being a one hit wonder I was so
happy to have that one hit when I had it
but um it was really cool to see that
good for you in some regards better than
driver's license that was really cool um
grateful for everyone who streamed those
songs thank you so much
what is Olivia Rodrigo vampire about
Olivia Rodrigo vampire is about me
because all my songs are about me and
they're introspective and they're about
nothing
else